all right it's time for another video i
want to thank everyone else who's new
again for subscribing because it seems
like there's a lot of you today and that
is sweet um just to give a quick little
rant before i start today's video
um i hope that all this stuff has been
useful just as kind of like a primer for
those of you who are first starting to
look at this channel
i see a ton of systems design channels
out there and that's great and i'm
trying to make myself unique for most of
those by you know starting to do deeper
dives and actually providing something
of value to you guys because the reason
i started this channel was i read
designing data intensive applications
like probably a lot of you have or will
do at some point if you're watching this
and then you're going to wonder well
what do i do from here how does this
actually translate to a systems design
interview and how do i actually hone my
skills in a way that you know reading
that book was worthwhile and that's
where i hope this channel comes in i
mean i literally see a million computer
science videos on youtube and they're
all so useless like it's you know tips
and tricks to put on your resume and
this is how i got my internship and like
those channels are literally all more
redundant than a replicated database and
at the end of the day like i'm just
trying to provide something of value to
you guys and you know hopefully help out
the community as a whole so without
further ado i'm going to do a pretty
introductory video on caching which you
could probably get from other channels
but for the sake of completeness on my
channels i want to do it and then i am
going to do a deep dive into some of
those in-memory services that you can
use in order to kind of implement
caching on a distributed scale all right
okay so introduction to caching well
what is caching caching is a super
useful thing that pretty much any super
large at scale system is going to need
where you are basically going to provide
lower latency reads and oftentimes even
rights to the end user
just this is generally done either by
improving data locality which means you
hold the data closer to the user or
you're using some faster form of data
storage and in distributed systems what
that generally means is you're storing
data in ram as opposed to disk
caching accomplishes three main things
the first one is there are going to be
fewer network calls to the database
which is probably going to be further
away than where your cache
systems are located
additionally if you ever need to do huge
computations or you know if you're
making a duplicated request to a server
you can store a bunch of pre-computed
values we've spoken about this in
analytics processing with something like
data cubes and then finally
it reduces the read load on the database
heavily and possibly even the right load
by virtue of intercepting a bunch of
these operations and handling them on
their own
okay so what are the main tradeoffs of
caching well there are a ton of pros
here and you know obviously they're cons
but if there weren't so many pros not
everyone would do it but here are the
pros the pros are hugely faster reads a
read from a cache can be well over in
order of magnitude which means 10 times
more than a read from a database
however if we attempt to find our data
in the cache and it's not there
which is called a cache miss then having
that cache is going to slow things down
so there are kind of
a couple of scenarios where this can
happen
one of them is called thrashing
thrashing is when you know let's say we
have a small cache and me and my friend
are both trying to
load our facebook profiles but when i
load my profile and it's originally not
in the cache now we have jordan's
profile on the cache then he loads his
so now his is in the cache it's actually
replaced mine because it was such a
small piece of cache and then i try and
load mine again now mine is no longer in
the cache we have a bunch of cache
misses and we've actually slowed things
down quite a bit
this can also happen because of poor
cash eviction policies i guess thrashing
is technically an example of a poor cash
eviction policy but you know generally
there are other poor cash eviction
policies as well that aren't just you
know because the size of the cache was
too small
additionally caches can potentially
improve the speed of rights and i'll
touch upon that in a bit
the biggest con is the increased
complexity of each right or generally
speaking just you know kind of the
schema that you're going to use to keep
the data and the cache valid and up to
date
this is kind of a design by design type
of thing and obviously there are
trade-offs for each design but you
really have to think about what users
need for your application and then make
the right decision here there's not one
objectively correct answer for any
approach
so what are some cash eviction policies
well first of all let's start by
discussing what a cash eviction even is
like i said generally speaking we're
storing our cache data in ram
ram is more expensive and as a result of
that most computers don't have a lot of
ram and so generally speaking when you
get a bunch of data in your cache
eventually you're going to have to evict
some of it which means that there's
newer newer data which would be better
off going in the cache and you're going
to have to get rid of some older data
so what i've done here is i've listed a
bunch of cache eviction policies but the
truth of the matter is most of these
suck and the only one that you should
really be using probably out of these is
least recently used you'll see i wrote
sliding window at the bottom there which
actually can work very well but it's
kind of still a matter of research and
it's not as widely implemented so for
now let's ignore that and just say that
least recently used is the most valid
one and so you know if it comes up in a
systems design interview or something
and they're like how might you implement
this this is a lead code problem and the
answer is a doubly linked list and a
hash map every single time you access
something that means it's been recently
used so you put it at the head of the
linked list and if you're going to
delete something from there you have to
delete it from the doubly linked list
and delete it from the hashmap
okay so now we have a couple types of
cache that we can actually think about
because the question is you know wow all
of our application servers are accessing
the database and all of the results from
the database are going through the
application server so wouldn't it make
sense for us to just use the application
server's ram as a cache
and the answer to that is well kind of
but not really so even though the
application server cache helps a lot
because it means that you don't have to
make any extra network calls hitting
some dedicated cache server
the fact that each server has its own
cache means a couple of things means
that one
all of those cache results are kind of
limited to that server another server
can't really access them
two is that if that application server
dies the cache goes with it and three is
that if you want you know to add a bit
more cash or you know add more servers
without adding more cash
application servers are going to scale
linearly with the application server
cache so generally speaking what most
people choose to do is use a global
cache and you know this might be
something like redis or memcache but
some service that actually allows you to
use nodes as an independent cache
and you know obviously we'll talk about
those services in a future video but
generally speaking global caches are
good because they scale independently of
the application server cache and they
also don't die when an application
server does
and additionally they can be accessed by
any application server and then
furthermore because we have all of these
nodes they can be replicated and
partitioned in any schema that we want
and we'll see this in play eventually
okay so in terms of keeping cache
updated because we know that obviously
we want to be able to get fast reads
from the cache however if we're writing
data which most applications are
generally speaking the data in the
database is changing over time you don't
want a ton of stale data in your cache
so obviously you can just have
you know cache data eventually expire
after say a couple hours and then when
you re-access it it'll be repopulated
with the newest stuff but generally
speaking you don't want to just wait on
some time for it to expire and you want
to kind of take a more active approach
in keeping the data up to date so i'm
going to look at three approaches of
writing in a system that implements
cache and we'll see kind of the
trade-offs of each of those
so the first is actually going to be
right through cache so just to quickly
explain this diagram the computer is
basically going to be like a client and
you know let's assume there's just some
application server that is attached to
that
the red thing is the diagram for redis
but for right now let's just call that a
cache server and then that silver thing
is the database
so
the right through cache is basically
doing the following we're going to write
both the cache and the database at the
same time in parallel and obviously a
write is going to be successful once you
get successes from both of those
if you have you know thought about this
a little bit you can see that this is
going to be pretty problematic in the
sense that anytime you're writing two
different things over the network it is
probably going to require some sort of
distributed or atomic transaction unless
you really don't care about the
consistency that much
you know if we have to do an atomic
transaction what that means is that we
probably need two-phase commit
because you know these aren't identical
replicas of one another so we can't just
use raft here what we do probably need
is two-face commit with a coordination
manager and as a result that's gonna
really slow down the rights
another option is right around cash so
what you do here and this is probably
the most simple implementation of
writing with a cash system is you just
write to the database as expected and
then the other thing you have to do is
also invalidate the current cache data
for that key so you basically just go to
the cache and say delete the data for
this key
the client is then going to eventually
request to read from the cache for
whatever data it is that you updated
and then eventually what's going to
happen is the cache is going to say wait
i don't have that database give me the
data and then report it back to the
client
so that's obviously decently simple but
the the issue with that is it's going to
result in a cache miss the first time so
now moving on to the third scheme we
have right back cache so this one's
pretty interesting we actually write
data only to the cache at first
and then eventually the data is going to
go from the cache to the database
possibly even in bulk and that way we
make fewer network calls to the database
and make sure that
everything is actually going to get
there in one piece
so even though this approach has a fast
write speed it's definitely got its
downsides
in the case where we can't deal with
eventual consistency such as something
like changing a password because
obviously you need the most updated
thing to be in the database which is our
source of truth
right back is not going to work
additionally since all of our data in
the cache is going to be in memory
if we were to write some data to the
cache and then that cache went ahead and
failed
then we just lost our right so maybe
that's not the hugest deal to have lost
rights but in some systems it certainly
is so in that case write back cash is
unacceptable
what if we wanted to be able to have a
slight modification of write-back cash
where we actually achieved some sort of
cash consistency so not only would we
use write-backs that clients see fast
rights on their end but additionally
when another server say wants to read
that data that may have been modified we
make sure that they're actually reading
the stuff that could still potentially
be in that cache
well the way we could do this is by
using something like a distributed lock
service so i've mentioned zookeeper and
at cd in the past and you know those are
based on coordination services and
consensus algorithms to work and
basically what's going to happen here
is every single time one server wants to
read a piece of data that may have been
modified by a cache
we know that any cache server that has
modified a piece of data in order to do
so must grab a lock for that object from
the lock service
and so when another server wants to read
it it'll basically say to the lock
server okay i'm trying to read this data
the lock server will say okay i'm going
to have to kick the cache server off the
lock and the cache server will then say
okay but before i get off the lock i'm
going to go ahead and send my
modifications back to the database so
that other people can go ahead and read
this
so that's kind of one way of dealing
with that if you've ever heard of the
frangipani file system
this is kind of the approach they took
where
you could make cash rights on your local
machine but if anyone else wanted to go
ahead and read your rights from a remote
machine
the local machine would have to give up
its locks and send those changes back to
the central server store
obviously the the downside of this is
that since only one server can hold the
lock at a time it's going to greatly
reduce both the write and read
throughput of whatever object it is that
you're trying to modify
okay so in practice i've kind of
talked about cache right now as this
abstraction where it's just like a
single memory server
and the truth of the matter is that's
obviously not acceptable
if the cache server goes down
we want it to be available or at least
the data that it held to still be
available
if a cache server isn't big enough to
hold all the data that should be getting
cached
it probably needs to be partitioned
cache servers need to be able to
coordinate with one another or
communicate with one another to say
who's up and who's not and additionally
sometimes it's not even sufficient to
just search by keys and values sometimes
we want something like secondary indexes
so in practice we have all of these you
know third-party services that have been
built on top of you know the idea of
caching but they add all of these
concepts that we talked about in the
past in this channel and so we're
actually going to take a look at those
next and that's things like redis and
and memcached which i think is a little
bit more simple than redis but we're
still going to end up talking about them
both
so in conclusion caching is a super
important part of any distributed system
with a ton of users and users that kind
of need low latency
it greatly improves read latency and
depending on the design of your actual
system possibly even the right latency
if you're using something like a right
back cache
generally speaking you want to be
decoupling your cache services from your
application servers so that they can
grow independently and scale on their
own and also not fail if a server does
but of course this comes at the cost of
having to make additional rpc or network
calls every single time you're updating
or changing the cash
and then in terms of rights in a system
with cash being implemented
we want to use right-back cash for
minimal right latency but of course
that's at the cost of eventual
consistency of you know the cash and the
the database which you know may not be
feasible for your use case
um if you want maximum consistency
between the cash and the database then
right through is your move however it
requires two phase commit or some sort
of other atomic commit algorithm which
is going to slow things down quite a bit
and then right around cache while being
the most simple comes at the cost of
having an initial cache miss every
single time you go ahead and make a
write to the database so that the cache
can actually repopulate itself with the
correct data
okay guys i hope this serves as a decent
introduction or primer to caching i'm
going to go much more in depth
in terms of actual services that you can
use for caching
and possibly even what existing
companies have done to make caching work
for them and keep everything consistent
and coherent